hey guys i'm ryan right as you may
notice i cut my hair finally like a lot
of you guys wanted me to I hate my hair
now that if I can hate it it looks like
[ __ ] dude it's like a bad Jew law Erica
you know okay I'm not homophobic at all
I have plenty of gay friends but this is
seriously what a lesbians haircut can
look like sometimes man I don't feel
comfortable with it and I decided to
shave too this is what I do for you guys
i sacrifice how I feel about my looks to
be more beautiful for you and with that
note what I wanted to do is explain real
fast over the next couple weeks I have a
lot of free time on my hands right now
so I'm gonna be posting a lot more
videos than usual over the next couple
weeks about probably two like July 19th
i'll just be without a date what I
wanted to do I wanted to do people have
been really loving the rap shoutouts to
freestyle shoutouts which i think is
cool I wanted to do this after the end
of these two weeks once I could go I
could see who are the top 25 subscribers
who viewed our videos the most in those
past two weeks and whoever those top 25
subscribers are we are literally going
to write and record and do a small music
video nothing too fancy okay of a song
that is dedicated to those top 25
subscribers so if you wanna be in that
video watch our [ __ ] it's that simple
it's that simple anyway yeah just want
to make that little announcement get
ready shits about to get crazy